hi guys welcome my name is lee boonstra
from work at customer engineer for
google and that myth that help in the pre
sales process customers with and creating
product eye for answering questions
about mark google-product
and have background in shopper
development
so cool was melancholy  that dog
built chicken coop j'y suis très
die very rz yes bella i have it too
technical tab he runs the coop about
how we can extend on top of the sweet
when it's in your own applications or
whether you wanna ride
coat om top of the  sweet that it is
basically the idea of how you want to exten
and have to that we read you sound
i the up script approach that means
like it is t we in the google domai
serve
jeans waitom one and alright me too c
ld to top of the suite  with you can
you that there is absolutely the other approach
that is to google pia is there is
have my application and a host this
somewhere but live brings me did a
in site of my apps
because i have meeting there  from the sweet in
site of my applications
so deliverdd app power on his wit
you will polly some chic voucher on duty
paws on am curious how many
developer will here in the room a
lot ah many people save
me from merchants who really learn from learning bit more
on
for the people afterwards empty again into
king the great idea to building
applications are also cover-up state
meter that is our wiggle design editor
get you quickly can create applications
basically my dripping and dropping would
it be zero cote and that we can a
dressing is  well
the let's talk about app script first
how it is there on script and up script
specifically javascript but this bran sanne
server server lesson that it needs less the
arno and no service ar service there
a gloomy with google takes care of at
and how dizlayki  javascript coat and save
it was in a browser
but i just keep in mind i wish
amber ana google server and gift
the act in our lesson like all these nine
sepia is this google ep  ice and services
they are already there a lot within your app
script and warming
a crime you can create your own a
dancer extensions where teams and the big
ed because it is here that launcher you the
trap script
this no longer not the white already had  dat
is op in taking care of you got in the
way how you can secure your applications
de developers hier probolinggo aan de
stem slijk yes to set up that could be
difficult
because yes it is albino already in a in den
warm en then van the sweet  so that is
next to and on and white you also have us the
lot of other tools lite monitoring tools
and balking
and man diego and then they find your chances
in the marketplace there in the chrome
web store
oh you can have the internal lay wind
shared their
in general for different entry point and
if you want your write up script out why
would you start and
it  kelen she  ets parents seem relation
between your coat and that [ __ ] oh I already
that container job script
so this was my documents hans fit
together bundled with your coat and on
the branch through the cold what you must fresh push
and jirko you must be corpse document
monkey  en and get active document or get
active spreadsheet you would have
reference does off active tempo got
fit and then you know start king to the
keyword write some triggers selected
time and he open this document from
execute disk space of kotor I
have edit this this  document
sometimes i with coat in the
background that sell the you off the setup
with earth and panty pointee be like
it's not building villages tickler
documents sheet and this case you would
create like like you we enter normal
web application but what up script zul
you have to koto script dat google.com
or you go to your google drive
but van der you open the app script
it not native editor and then you are able to
coding your scripts over der and w  at
typically my people aim is than one you
execute one you're on such a piece
ofcold en de show en file picker en de
user can select de de sheet door
documents t niet en dan je know I stand
there cue ding de cote tablet  tomorrow user
bob
to the er so to the ranch point that
is more like adwords
it strike in in case you doing stuff
the election
you can also give us roteb script cold from
kiosk account which runs on the server
but this is private for the word
and the  la slang aldo app meeker in small
red door to are there again not for sale
you can kotick you want and their then you
have the choice between ormel javascript
kotor as led strip and then
negram the fire under server double talk
about is suffering so keep  there
the script is running otavio and seem simple demon
how you could you that with first
and she becomes a developer he must now he is
good rita medion so out coteaux du
enboksen en page of google third
billy explainer pretty highlight all the
de epa with he  t stairway receipts kind
start using i know for container job
script or if it's for your own web
applications they so much bal der and that is
jeff and do you want the starting point where
to start
in this case old are you
staring at the google drive opening my
native editor google-app script and chose
photo script which google.com and why can
i create in this example and can on
conference application where a speakers
can upload their presentation and every
time and presentation on sap
red devil get an email it  ace more
five times to tasted the presentations
and cherry tree it
think this is a very simple application
by use case that thank everybody [ __ ] yes
create
so becomes what you did it can you go to
their google drive you create and folder
and you don't get the share  dat folder die cause
and all the other speakers can upload
their presentation and their
dan win you do that you get en
ali  people prefer to win a cold
so in o'er no the editor new york reason
variable
slide folder ideal and that then
suddenly the koterij just got it in their
and also extension javascript code
barry see in this kees icreative
ferryboot folder and he c light
drive-api geesjen I have a folder with that
and atk that the diamonds capite the neck thing
is on because the retweet already the phase that there is
in that folder
so you have a target that white folder that
jet fails and the next things online sex
why that  who's here
icreate i'm going to store you so
now it's already a cry of pain or
definitely a slayer lord
ze simple stories that ret almost next
weekend at open this is the script that had
this silent some way of malfunction which are
dirty  new a little dirty are
harold such a small of the well you
store with here is barry simple so that
mg tf the nek sing it a great fairy bow
new 480 pale
so has the chips for vlogging the
wife is new and and to we  look to
rolled pale
the f  ile greater that he creates for it
and if the cover tip the failure is new
and I the woman is new know the name
a this does the new failure array so der
to the hindu lamp that let me that leter
and we would commit the decided it
layer so next week winner of this
script and den that the new building lives
show patient and the last peace on the
coat
in this case icheck glycol harder and that
new paul's alias dr
ok om channel obdam om using basic
locking here
and al cents email  and the email that then
trude email eps
so i get a c gmail app that send email
what and my sending a scent an
email the active users buddhism and the
rival get and
forget your so that is  what a push in the
email and i restart testing it so the
bullying play button here at that moment
out will probably
silat message so i a co2 er basic
lamping
so fox and you have to soul and lab people it
seems what you see to the  touchscreen
the four men I have more advanced
all of a sudden pass word  t the your site driver
here and then you must correct console dot
log and then it was submit site driver
jf some schmeiser richer
site 2 6 and slowly that
are option for you this is keep the e-
mail by the look like and  ivory time
email
well that was first test shock and he
just brings your production
we don't setup such a project triggers'
in this case that means seem office of
is catchy let there be time that were
real source of icreate I understand the
project checkers  garnett and iso not
much
go to this process it's so little she
not to be a tent tender and not the up
your eyes myself hurt her blue 2
opened the drive books and also the
the email heavily review the permissions
je  catwyck an egg salad
daddy and yo hello that daddy i see it
our we and nitrites a penny in the lee
texas for for gmail it if
necessary not to offer kees wrap
all that standing an e-mail or whatever
sweet or someone there  something email from the
family gmail  account and you will not
pro of deed and he us so not whole i
have my studio to the great wide and
accept the trigger and the discrete
created time trailer a trigger for 5
minutes and every 5 minutes to start
running the script en en it caesar
new phase in a set my email if
there are any
this all hands-on the google server
there cup of thing without also map for
i pre script and and and adams in
general and one of the sting the
incentive is your thumping her  like
big l soon week and probably create
get of templates and in gmail that je
kin auto with the qicent
verpoort so we slide us also at-at us
feature a user likes likes and they do
some of the scan of toxins and very happy
with dad  that is actually in early access
programs or if you because you can drive
hall speak is de voor de en alzo
mobile en dans zo if you create app
script for for dachser never
am I will also work on your mobile
phone and works to your mobile  phone
through the brow  ser but a oh no tips if
all android yes let's take a look into
this second approach to be the good guys
google supports like many many languages
all usual
y come the popular because i about nokia
kind of javascript java that just ruby if th
already  bale and cow language
google it already client s the case for all
this language and you can start your
downloading sister sdk and then
implements in your own web application
so discrete organize part is we know
integrate the sweet in my phone
application to such an epic client
est ikea juliet al de en points and
which you can get
is relax study google drive for to
use which
salami show your neck lamp or that i
know it a simple application
let myself who had week we live there to
create for my google home and want
to make sure that google hall must rita
palma emails and the roads were too expensive
that is by putting all my email herders
in a chic and in addition google hunter
drove the [ __ ] to
yes so leak  ker food that wit emergency esq be
with javascript developer
every now and then and pm downloaded the package
sexting is in my google cloud go to the
gmail epa and he not en ebola ice zo
rvp highlight i want i usually to make
sure did you first enable  it and it that
moment you can unload monitor and soul
icahn mount of users that has been used
to your epa and you know secure its own doctor got
sick learned people can study using
the epa is it want here
allsecur clerk yes with payment date from
google
you  set object credentials get out this
is icreate and jason fail
jesus said yes the credentials choose
service account week roll and he fries
in my wife and my full the structure
and that service account contains all
the information of can it connect to
my account
he can't corner  put setup and whitelist
off
lenny to start looking into a la thuile
to that can be tricky but luckily the sdg
chf support for that so you know start
using the prix define cold of
from google and that's w  at he did in
this case icreative first out generated
a url to test chain cake pan in
which you like and look into my own
google account so that the moment this note
it's about join in the archive really the
chair shirt a fail she folders
arie der weck  i have three direct to the
frontpage and i have a new gold and
white dakota
you create and an outro already object
must want through bert smoke and party this is
he wrote time in my folder
structure so an extra with also not
the coach there so hall  processes already know my
name localhost
na de de cote coat is not do they
forgot yder he start on
implementing the packages right out of the sea but
ricquier the google epa is and require the
google old library wouldn't he
push all the lead rod myself  recognize your
face p set of words the archer rice I
dove it new and the dump can also
functions
he not the divine scopes after a this
case already because I give you access to gmail
so there is the scope for that and he also
c  reate the folder where he
but point to the folder where icesave the
service token all my heart travel in
need yeah scanf indeed old
this is the agile coach the submarine
myself
by looking into the documentations sc
gmail dat users'
messages knew so want your tri  -fold
e-mails that there in my inbox and in
this case agree on a great
zo die is new messages that are
coming in a my e-mailbox
me this moment broncos is a callback
what you see here in the my dream
apps social  media and where message in
site driver give i am find and it gets
into here and and he safe the emails in
which emails
try this with ideal your profile
i choose which might be one timmert
rives the third party of the e  -mail and the
and so object would you then you become she
gmail that jesus that girls that cat and
your query to the ai that jazz sadness and
that moment and you have all those emails and
this he becomes before this gets into me
more to the call-to-actions my
spreadsheet and safe  it seems in the
but there are many ep eyes is that your
kid starts using for google drive for
calendar
gmail you take to it there are three google
projects hes and an ep ai that you know
start using and playing around it
define developer he becomes and of a
look into whitby katlijk google meet that's how you
make cousin thing track yo you can get
isolated start start using free
the jackets and next in line
like to look into this app maker and
maybe of see that in the keynote earlier
today
this is our  visual spot a joke his
editor your concrete applications what you
know the necessary not for sale and he
all show you already said madame all my
show and the studio application
and he creates in anger in 5 minutes how
it is king so tracking and dropping
yes  zo spauwen full of apps for for your
business the key benefits in this case is
let you can create applications veryfast
is already integrated within the sweet would you
can make use of al
de dit is die ctp yes is the google hey
guys  you can also make use of the google
cloud platform component so for xm
polyvalent story your detail in the cloud
week to you can easily be disconnected and
and setup
theta bonding so once you have like your
date a in your application you can vary
them songs at  a tattoo were then
widget and the wheel you see ton the pipe and
the last things and direction is
compliant and secure i have if it is in the
google domain already securit and nobody'll
screencap there that also means that your
building applications for domain en  at
want for for fake store yes dissenters
de yes de brush with lord of
companies and developers hair again and the
price is want to create applications
just go to google who have lots of
business problem pose how someone
coach the soul and job I shake him
velper to code and then deadpool take
maybe a month with guys would it be
integrated yourself very easily at
prototyping ghetto you concrete the
production version within a few days
think about dashboa  rd az trekkers bit
ark
program city margret this is a very very
essential nrw body kit start using
it being suffocation at once in your
browser
magua that bicycle white jeans business
account can easily just log in and start
playing there well with the beast then open
standards
age the meltdown scripps here six it
also works nights on mobile
so it seems to me material design look and
feel
that brandsma of being leaves like
an azone desktop yes you don't get that again the
software developers
so instead of talking about this let me
show  you a demo die created on how you
can create and application
men these are semi live demo have the cb
calls and recorded it the cash register you were
also
fearwijk bart influences bit holder garden
and it is probably bad there in five
joshua video both the cote d'  or the video
got quite right step peacock sits and
what you see here is the
the app meter so the thief on screen you
start setting up the project and and
the first thing that have thing  en
typically modules you would create a
model and a model that is like
describing in the entity
and in antique for sample cubio churning
churning churnen are prints caracol there is the
number of wales
on properties of certain time that je
niet die define and then you find it  to
some details of tkb stuart called for
peta and it is also in there push here
but those for pset will select the google
drive table at least the exact one in
player will be in the google drive for
can safe or the detail in it in
google drive
but there other be what you push
it for sample your herbs
she bothers in classic well hear you [ __ ]
like by it indeed wax know
so you can selected
in this case on this creating me for
months or so and men 17th google drive
naughty  and eating the [ __ ] altheer so
quarter create then try to do this
application
would i have the man take the take table
and then can be create some fields
for the bag fashion or
in my mouth and [ __ ] roadtrip fiel  ds via
see the story huh media database export
and your man to retrieve all the fields of
is doing here to clothes the
driver ran so my creative field
stands knees and task take will be your
string and yes that moby to save take the
third or  the language the next indeed is
part is already creative scrolls cake did
neptune market my the task was created
led sphere that did on the time
he knows you select and the last of
the bible goal is already create and feel
potkamp leader which will be a boolean
time to stain in me complete it the
shelter yes or no to go for a ride
now and then white white did have
white madam he [ __ ] connected is
pointer databases and staff play but
can push toms can crater very
simple application he create some pages
credit for  me applique china do not become your
pages is the main screen there also
go to one all the components
and then what pre the case and time we so
the at spring there obia papa with a
floating form recognize
create new the box e  n and he will be
shown on the my friend so that's what
then doing here creators opaque page and
he wants
to take again really i think
import and keep take picos this is
also buy you ever and sit leter
so stop  mae cable needed ok but what
you see doing here then click the
on the widget button and it knows
select widgets why can't choose from
forms for tables of are already type's app
component charger and in this case size
selects the label component and  what
i sit there automatic' i recognize my
model and can you fashion this the bag on the
form so i want there the highlight at it
sounds create this table well here and
is so want in aysist show did the
bonding and pray i was i well  sit
next to the fashion label automata click
create all the columns form in the Crimea it
would seem knows exactly all your kidney
the task names and that's a string zoey
sort improve it all order well
the did dearest be sorted on it did
became its possible our to enabl  e paging
the radio stations that you see here to the
options cream but then doing here is a
just so to resizing a position the
great nicely under screen oldies point in
the stairs and he as well your wit and eyes
wit
one is a my shirt it  is van bram
sunny from
and my new that was testing it anne
laptop tam
after an then with that abel print further
component to the states and in this case
it will be a form and know create and
edit form or eat form
so i have that way  selectest then i
want
chotin in the in this form and i know this
work it after is the fashion so we
put and looked the test model
date to date abiding and real time and
to select the shelter see the task in the
edit screen
and  you know if that formica does the box
like so pull that shape in silk or
the bottom always out yeah we so a
resizing to make sure this at night
die online and up-trap then time to 0
create and edit and
so  none opened the pop-up screen to at
new
yes new component  will pull button
there and him in and select talking
give the take this is the take or the
button eva want to refer to meet buys
and i have it in the text so you see
how it looks like to the screen oh yes you
are the bidvest
yes and slowly then me that i you can
click to click
to click many here and here you will c
seems ok why have him and he
selects already in this case a will open
the app scream and a yes you can design the
at screen-  door punching bags missing and
minute as stairs vibrate so after you your
design touchscreen is and then you
can preview the beard and so this will be
here and neatly see the application in a
house in the browser edge and created
a this is the pop-up
I'm talking about dating
and seeing the strawberries I have afterwards is
did component
he sat mid and once it's there icon
selects and that core as if equality
s complete and because they complete particles
see the that so complete it in the in
the stairs lead
okay
that's how [ __ ] deta  il didn't use and the
coding mr wimps dripping and dropping
what women to make it more a
customs
he cruise and could use some king
jesus not such that javascript
knowledge that camtasia allow my script to the
client in the browser  then you just
right normal janske cold I hear him
that app script coat
what you buy ipad in the ab script itself and
vending machine i teach you you make use of all
the google epa is and yes you can stark
army but it so app make it will  be
able in queue for you because you know
start player budget that is not the
bie and choose white business customer and you
can also to this page unique and margin
even weekend start player raw chicken
thigh fillet it was your tattoo player
already I'm sitting there  so easy to create an
application and well dees and member state then it
seems to him this leo koster from
foxy cool hey very great yes business
applications create and here they are allowed
bart
[Applause]
thank you
hi hi meer koster oh and enterprise
software co  mpany
this has been successful in business since night
in ethical say and more or one of the
first inholland
to be available on the inernet online
into they man wat er was a happy
some free years ago and realized that we
were not moving 15af
distress innovating hart  in loose paper
to cells for future challenges en he
is marcel what is happening
sees the worldchanging en software
rolled in
it's about new customer sashimi
questions at koenen en char en he is such
a new type' of empirical coming
that were switching from software
thermostat tot  a to use to
share software using and that became a a
young mission to create software for the
business user that part a and to be able
to deliver because it bros wii deer
create something completely new you from
scratch
and there is foxy foxy like want  problem
we have kip unite shampoo am your
night the services company and your
successful and you're growing the first
thing you put into place is something on
the  back and te
for a financial solution to take care
of your invoicing and cash collection
and when you come over to putting
santing into place to attract customers
and type it
outbound inbound marketing what in the
means to it's ok if combining
or different app custom  solutions peper
you take it foxy turns into is murder and
efficient process
my business apps
let me introduce to you willem willem
loos
founder and ceo of whatever launching
customer willem willems job is to put
use some one of holland's most famous
export product
parties they started out my  per using de
shows of dj tiësto
nou 30 using
bicky corporate events worldwide
en met f en vent dp juice tons of
information
portico planning resource planning rick
in planning sound planning light
planning en sketches die tot ski maas
massive amount of data and they share
this with  hundreds of people
temporary employee customer contractor
she could tractors and banishment and afterwards
is connected and worki  ng together
collaborating om zwieten en jeans wit en
labelt willems crow a little further with
willem was miss you something
inside game us with a tassel
why can't ai find and business app
er is integrating of that information
from the sweet
interesting in a can look at  that my
phone
why marbles wat een willem is per using
is events' worldwide
this is is office at taxi en in this case
section in tokyo the backseat op de taxi
is is office and i want to be able to
sit there and never look at this  phone
and to see whether this project would
omtrek with people productive is
invoices going out en de man i coming in
and of course be tot in look no further
how to
see epoxi wat is foxy volks is a
vertical solution for very specific
market is for professional  services
met voor everybody who is delivering
services
football jacks met highly skilled
professionals onderhoek
wat sets foxy apart let's freezings
de force one is a social user
experience withteken de best ik  simples
of social media to the business pees
lief sign the timeline the activity
stream when the business user and house
at helping the closet ben noah die hercules
any more work and i find it the most
commonly
ask question with business users and we
have enough it ar
with foxy des victor how they help your
mother a mobile first
that wants to offer juices pico's in the couple of years
there won't be any more mobile first it
will be mobile oil and the fairphone is
a no-brainer lucas google
cloud dozing platform with
next-generation cow is using foxy
account manager responsible for the
customer
the project manager responsible for the
project's the professional the engineer
consultant who sheets developer the mini
actual job
the manager and the support fabric in the
back office
and howard in working together in
discotheque s process  and chose like that it
starts with die kan manager grating the
quote ben ecostore the organization
manager at per die fought for the
process
the sex pensiv  e in pin purchase
invoices provide king old and also
hey miko back and too fast
you guys here and then you do is there a
multitool or am at home perhaps it can be
many meet manager rand
blessum again and the crew solving
here is
weekend overs not  only have information
and secondly the right time to do my
job is she over them offers minnow box
persona such as roles in professional
services and foxy thor's this into
smothered speedy and efficient process and
keeps the who does that well this again
develab foxy
men who new it  u start from scratch
istar it looking at becomes other
successful
software companies for doing and there
or making use of other people's hard
work
there were using platforms platform
service and then my inventory of all the
available
platforms and family the most innovative
the most of the most  technology best
was the google cloud platform and i
looked already that fit this is the great
something beautiful and win formula
it sometimes starting points
doe ff little is possible use what is
available because i want to be able to
buddha minimum viable product' old under
market with this little effort as
possible and as soon as possible
youssef went by google maps at global
billion nu sheetfed press zo  even devops is
the god damn was how u want u those fierce
nomobs oh sorry lescaut beckers building
santen in new for disconnected world
mexx eau license 4 global and
mission so skill is import and design
for scalability and for business
user security is of paramount importance
and
met google cloud platform and working
together with chi's sweet briquettes debt
securities
being om de cow cloud platform allows to
have very clean and simple architecture
mi love clean and simple
jf just one front end
often another known for matched by
google app  engine and the details disturbs
in the cloud better store
nothing more simple and in our pursuit
of nomobs wie you some other
google product
old  there come teams that fold coin is fully
automated
with jenkins om computer engine who
monitor foxy
by using google analytics and the
combination still driver and bigquery
and who slice and the requirements the information
how it streaming the date a to agree and
analyze it with this  studio here are
ex apples of the integration which i
switch force one s user management
identity management ever user and
specially the business user is called soaring
us his thing in a specially has de
hef to sign in to different applications
to to to complete my job
wie stitch  once of dead by using
the google account wit them in the middle of
signing in choose the ride account and you
dan
and other shampoo first malfunction dna and
expect knows how they forgot is there is
to cat users to store the date with the
right but you  're right customers right
on retirement it is' who your provider with
display like and so rail om button here
and you click and you go exec lead to the
right
folder om managed to write ep ar  s
there dino's des accountmanagers
love to copy of quotes and very a copy
a plague and muscovites die tells about
other problems that that it is creating
so sweet made it easy for them to just
click one button cry a new big
and it is created with red template
turns settings indeed folder and
is ready for them to edit
so when for sending out quote
get notified online timeline put the zipper
time family old shot
somebody else test this
click on the button and it can be entered
did our samsom van point
nobody likes  to enter did anymore and
watch you your and google so
judge find information
here and creating a new organization
with the contact person i am looking up
the travel company and fill the google
places ep high select this select by
out contact for plus epa in and
marnef entered  and now you'll be there
garfield
with the contact information the right
pictures logos and then
management and support staff part
cheats for reportin  g
so who creates the bunch of something for him
and teachers financial exon pom and table
sheets
interviews and who those sheets thoronet om
with app script
tour version detail in we de gate
and last but not least
in malfunction foxy fuji fuji sweet
marketplace for using  that sepia
to get foxy tour to get foxy in to get
back yes i have faction interior own
domain
with all the law settings for the red users
that was the last i sample
curious where the foxy should you stay
there in the my den
you have any  questions discus
do you think layer tankje leo het pre and
process at apg sensotec family dit de
foxy book so well you have seem like their
various pointed in how you can create a
free claesen's you knew the trap script
you can because with your own codebase and
disintegrate  the google is epa and she is the
leaf ear you can make juice
and with at our like to thank you for
being here which you were great day and
i got you some lunch oh thank you
fine
[Applause]